cette sensation que je suis à
l'intérieur de la mine et j'ai cette
angoisse
oir Daniel Herrera
Daniel bonsoir dans la nuit du 13 au 14
octobre dernier la terre entière a suivi
en direct l'opération de sauvetage la
plus médiatique de tous les temps 33
mineurs bloqués depuis 69 jours à 700
mètres sous terre remonter un par un
grâce à une capsule métallique
spécialement dessinée par la NASA un
vrai scénario de film hollywoodien dont
vous avez été Daniel l'un des héros à
20h vous nous raconterez le suspense de
70 jours avant la happy end
[Musique]
Daniel Herrera rebonsoir vous êtes né le
20 janvier 1983 à Santiago du Chili
votre père était conducteur de bulldozer
et votre mère officier d'état civil
alors vous êtes un enfant proche de
votre maman et de vos tentes vos oncles
vous surnomme elle aussi tôt gominolo le
nounours
hariboque
et c'est pour ça qu'on m'a appelé comme
ça à la maison alors vous êtes pas très
intéressé par l'école vous faites des
petits boulots jusqu'au jour où votre
oncle vous achète une voiture pour faire
le taxi
et je l'ai fait pendant trois ans à peu
près c'est là que vous entendez parler
d'un métier à risque mais qui vous
rapportera plus d'argent que le taxi
chauffeur de camions dans la mine de San
José alors la mine José c'est une mine
de cuivre et d'or qui est vieille d'un
siècle qui est dangereuse il y a
beaucoup d'accidents vous aviez peur
avant d'y aller la plume la toute
première fois oui j'avais vraiment très
peur faut dire aussi que dans la mine
comme chauffeur de camions vous gagnez
900 euros alors que le SMIC chilien est
de 300 euros
voilà c'est pour ça que j'ai accepté de
faire ce travail c'est le salaire de la
peur
alors en janvier 2010 vous savez même
pas un an vous mettez pour la première
fois le casque et la lampe frontale vous
dites j'étais terrorisé et je me
demandais si j'allais pas faire
demi-tour
j'ai décidé de rester pour toujours
travailler là alors vous aimez bien
l'ambiance dans la mine il y a une
ambiance un petit peu familiale et là on
peut dire que le nounours
introverti se fait des copains
et des bonne qualité faut dire que vous
êtes enfermé ensemble 12 heures par jour
et que vous partagiez cette angoisse de
ne jamais ressortir donc c'est ça qui
vous lie aussi
on partage énormément des choses à
l'intérieur de la mine mais donc on
devient de plus en plus amis avec les
autres est-ce que entre vous vous parlez
du danger constitue le fait de
travailler dans la mine de sainte rosée
ce qui est arrivé c'est arrivé le jeudi
5 août 2010 alors que vous êtes au fond
en train de fortifier un endroit ou un
collègue à vous a eu la jambe écrasée
par un éboulement huit jours avant la
terre se met à trembler et là vous dites
j'ai entendu la mine rugir
donc au début j'ai pas fait très
attention
vous savez que ça arrivait
l'habitude
compte combien cela être grave ensuite
vous voyez au bout du tunnel un nuage de
terre qui déferle vers vous comme une
avalanche
avec une forte odeur de terre mouillée
vous retrouvez les 32 autres mineurs qui
sont avec vous et là vous réalisez tous
ensemble que vous êtes piégé à 700
mètres sous terre vous vous dites quoi à
ce moment-là avec avec vos camarades
mineurs
la muerte la mort
c'est l'espoir qu'on avait bien sûr on
pensait que deux trois jours suffiraient
pour qu'on en sorte de là alors
l'éboulements à obstruer la rampe
d'accès qui descend en zigzag au fond de
la mine quand elle a cheminée de
ventilation l'échelle de secours n'a pas
été installé à temps
de fortune
et la moins courte
on pouvait même pas passer d'un niveau à
l'autre là vous brûlez les torchons
imbibés de pétrole pour faire des
signaux de fumée à travers la cheminée
de ventilation
aucune réaction
de
brûler une grande quantité car la fumée
pouvait se retourner contre nous
on a fait ce qu'on a pu à celle qui
s'opérer comment il sache
que nous étions
alors vous klaxonnez avec les camions
pas plus de réactions vous faites péter
des explosifs pour faire trembler le sol
mais rien ne se passe rien ne se passe
alors commence l'opération survie
vous trouvez un refuge de 50 mètres
carrés et un accès d'un kilomètre et
demi à la galerie entre les boulements
et le fond de la mine donc voilà ça va
être votre endroit sans savoir combien
de temps vous allez être là non
les camions vous servent à charger les
batteries de vos lampes frontales
questions vivre vous avez trois jours de
vivre deux bouchées de thon en boîte et
un demi verre de lait chacun tous les
deux jours et Clara oui on mélangeait
les lait avec de l'eau
on peut dire que c'était rien c'était
surtout de l'eau plutôt que du lait
est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui voulaient
manger plus
tout le monde
respecter la situation est-ce que
quelqu'un qui garde la nourriture pour
éviter que que les gens se jettent sur
la nourriture
et c'était au milieu de tout le monde
personne
ne pouvait essayer le problème c'est
qu'il fait une chaleur de 40 degrés
on a rien sur le dos il y a eu des
disputes à ce moment-là des cautionner
oui est-ce qu'il y a eu des bagarres
entre vous
deux
l'après-midi ou le lendemain quand on
faisait l'assemblée générale on le
faisait un public alors les jours
passent chacun trouve sa solution pour
ne pas craquer certains prix d'autres
dorment l'organisation est très rigide
le chef c'est Luis ourgeois qui était
déjà le chef et toutes les décisions
sont prises démocratiquement vous votez
pour toutes les décisions c'est
absolument
[Musique]
50 + 1 ça c'est voilà ce qu'on faisait
49% devaient accepter ce que le 51%
avait décidé voilà et puis le 22 août à
6h du matin après 7 jours d'angoisse
vous entendez du bruit contre la
paroisse de la galerie vous comprenez
qu'il s'agit d'une foreuse venue vous
porter secours ce bruit de la foreuse
vous allez vous y accrocher comme un
radeau pendant encore dix jours vous
dites lorsqu'elle s'arrêtait retombait
dans l'angoisse
d'assemblée
mais on a eu des hauts débats quand la
sonde perfore la paroi de la galerie
tous les mineurs se jettent sur la tête
de la foreuse pour l'embrasser c'est
vrai c'est vrai
on s'est rendu compte qu'il savait
maintenant qu'il y avait de la vie vous
l'avez embrassé la tête de la foreuse
le 26 août la sonde revient avec une
caméra et là le monde entier découvre
vos visages barbus le front luisant
une caméra on se demandait ce que c'est
alors voilà chacun dit un mot à la
caméra vous vous dites salut à ma
famille
sortez-nous vite de là s'il vous plaît
voilà le 29 août arrive le téléphone
alors là il y a quand même eu un
problème c'est qu'en fait il y a des psy
blog qui commence à censurer un peu vos
échanges et à un moment vous communiquez
avec votre famille et vous dites le
psychologue nous rend fou
essayer d'inventer psychologie pour
travailler avec 33 personnes mais je
crois pas que cela est fonctionnel
nous étions
et on avait désir de continuer voilà et
puis c'est le sauvetage quand vous
arrivez en haut vous êtes surpris par la
lumière malgré les lunettes que on vous
avait demandé de porter et alors votre
maman
qui vous avait promis de ne pas pleurer
elle pleure
en retrouvant ce nourrice sitôt votre
maman pleure
une grande émotion de la voir
alors vous êtes en bonne santé ça va
vous avez repris les 16 kg que vous avez
perdu dans cette aventure ça va là
est-ce que vous avez des séquelles
psychologiques
de temps en temps
je rêve cette sensation que je suis à
l'intérieur de la mine et j'ai cette
angoisse
qu'est-ce qui vous a fait tenir quand
vous étiez en bas c'est la foi
oui oui je suis quelqu'un
c'est là maintenant c'est beaucoup plus
fort ce sentiment alors aujourd'hui
quand vous pensez à votre avenir est-ce
que vous voulez retourner travailler
dans cette mine de sainte-crose
mais pas dans celle-là est-ce que les
les patrons de cette mine qui ne
respectait pas les les sécurités
élémentaires est-ce qu'ils ont été
sanctionnés par le pouvoir chilien non
pas encore
ce process on est en train de faire un
procélateur
on n'a pas encore trouvé le coupable
est-ce que vous avez eu l'impression
d'être instrumentalisé par le président
chilien
aurait profité de la situation
mais je pense que ça a été bien fait
nous on allait libération des
infirmières bulgares vous savez c'était
un peu pareil
un homme ordinaire qui devient
extraordinaire pas que c'est un
témoignage fantastique et très émouvant
qu'on venait nous donner monsieur je
sais pas si votre maman aurait envie de
vous voir retourner à la mine quelle
qu'elle soit
politique en général beaucoup
d'histoires finissent mal on regarde le
monde et on voit que la plupart des
histoires finissent mal vous c'est une
histoire qui finit bien ça fait chaud au
cœur de voir une histoire qui finit bien
au passage et puis une fois un nounours
Haribo aussi sympathique que ça ça
aurait été dommage
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu